cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus is here with more on this now david
uh you
you you seen the poll uh half of
americans
say they're not confident about taking
this vaccine
so should they should americans be
confident
well the answer is i don't know yet we
have to see the data and so it's very
hard when you see these polls because
there can be nobody
advocating yet for a vaccine because we
have to advocate with the data
here is the data how it works here is
the safety data and based on those
myself and i think many other doctors
will stand up and say you
need to take this vaccine it is critical
to your safety and the country
but again it really depends on the data
david one of the things we've heard from
so many doctors right now
is get your flu shot we are entering flu
season cases are on the rise when it
comes to coronavirus what other advice
do you have for people
as we are in this time
so obviously the double whammy of covet
19 and influenza or flu can happen
and so flu is preventable in large part
by getting a flu shot
we all have to step up and play our part
so getting a flu shot is critical
and then obviously it's the mask i mean
we saw we had
record numbers of cases happening now in
many states seventy plus
thousand cases yesterday and a thousand
deaths so numbers are going up
not going down as we enter the holidays
and as we enter the holidays dr aegis
thanksgiving
right around the corner here uh dr
reagan said this week he's not going to
visit his
uh dr fauci said he's not going to visit
his kids
on this this thanksgiving i know tens of
millions of families around the country
are thinking about this and talking
about this what should they do
luckily my kids are here so i don't have
to worry about that but it is a major
issue as we get into increasing numbers
and if
parents are elderly or grandparents are
there we have to have a lot of concern
for them so
thanksgiving this year is not going to
be like other years
no question about it at the same time as
we transition to indoors as weather gets
colder
we have to continue to socially distance
and wear masks especially when
interacting with others
where there's going to be more and more
trouble i mean the numbers are troubling
at the present time i can't say it in
any other way
well new research is out now from the
world health organization dr
agus saying that the effectiveness
of current covet treatments uh is
you know where are we why don't i just
ask you plain and simple
so rem deserver which was a antiviral
originally developed for ebola
now in a random well in a trial at the
world health organization 11
000 people got one of four different
drugs it did not change survival
the earlier study in the united states
showed that it decreased hospitalization
from 15 to 10 days
but this was a different study and this
is a study in sick or patients
multiple different countries the the
patients and how they were treated were
different in addition
we have dexamethasone now so a different
treatment to help the lungs
and in that setting remdesavir probably
is an active drug but it's not a great
drug we don't yet have a home run
my hope is the monoclonal antibodies
will be
maybe a triple a lot better treatment in
terms of treating the disease than
remdisaver is at the present time
okay dr agus thank you very much